es sind bilder die wir eigentlich nur
von nordamerikanischen gesetz kennen
doch dieser schwere schneesturm tobt in
der nacht auf der insel sieg peitschen
sturmböen vom meer kommend über die
insel
dabei führt der starke wind feuchtigkeit
der ostsee mit die über land als schnee
fällt der sogenannte lake effect binnen
zwei stunden fallen 20 cm neuschnee in
schwaben sind die zustände chaotisch
gerade geräumten straßen sind binnen
minuten wegen schneeverwehungen wieder
unpassierbar
selbst mit der schneefräse kommt der
winterdienst gegen die massen nicht an
die deutschem wetterdienst rechnen damit
dass auch am vormittag weiter schneien
wird allrad und schneeketten ist also
auch hier ein vorankommen com möglich
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren